hola
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no no
[Música]
apenas estamos en la mitad del recorrido
aún faltan 4 horas para el regreso
me siento cansada me duelen las manos
los brazos
cuándo
recuerdo que mi padre me dijo no tomes
riesgos innecesarios
estoy adentro de una cueva a más de 150
metros de profundidad
pero me quedo pensando riesgos
innecesarios pero que estoy diciendo yo
deseaba este momento yo quería estar
aquí me estuve preparando estuve
entrenando realmente lo deseaba
realmente me emocionaba así que gaby
tranquila
respira y ahora viene el verdadero reto
fue entonces que comencé el ascenso
recordé que no estaba sola
cada que subía por aquella cuerda me
representaba un reto centímetro a
centímetro
prácticamente seguir subiendo y cuando
por fin logré salir de la cueva
me sentía llena de adrenalina emocionada
feliz plena y me quedé sin palabras
cuando alcé la mirada y vi la luna
una luna tan impresionante como jamás la
había visto
esto soy yo
dentro de la cueva con cero glamour cero
filtros y una cara de pánico que no
podía con ella
quien de este lugar ha deseado algo con
todo su corazón aún cuando esto
represente sentir miedo o incertidumbre
así me sentía yo
cuántas veces hemos dudado de nuestro
potencial de nuestras habilidades
poniendo límites a nuestra mente ya
nuestro cuerpo
hace 7 años tomé la decisión de
adentrarme en este maravilloso mundo del
montañismo de una manera responsable y
de una manera consciente en la comunidad
montañista practicamos diferentes
actividades como escalada en roca
senderismo alta montaña y espeleología
el arte de explorar cuevas ahora pienso
en alexander von humboldt y en su gran
magnetismo y hechizo por las montañas él
decía que aparte de representarle un
esfuerzo físico y aparte de adquirir
nuevos conocimientos él encontraba en
las montañas algo trascendental decía
que cuando subía una montaña o cuando
estaba en una cima se sentía tan
conmovido por el paisaje que solamente
estaba en ese momento con total plenitud
y es que alexander humboldt también se
daba la oportunidad de sentir asombro
por supuesto que había que documentar y
analizar la naturaleza por supuesto pero
en una época en que los científicos
buscaban solamente leyes universales
humble quería despertar el amor por la
naturaleza
una de las mayores lecciones que la
naturaleza dejó a humboldt fue la de
libertad
pero saben yo creo que no es solamente
ver el paisaje creo que hay que aprender
a observarlo hay que aprender a
observarnos
ya que la naturaleza al igual que la
vida el tener la capacidad de estar
totalmente presentes en ella nos hace
vivirla con todos y cada uno de nuestros
sentidos
la montaña nos deja diferentes
aprendizajes a cada persona en mi caso
me mostró un camino al autoconocimiento
poniendo a prueba mis límites y mis
propias creencias encontré también en la
montaña que ante la adversidad podemos
superar cualquier obstáculo es solamente
ver alternativas las alternativas
posibles y humble decía que los
pensamientos jamás se estancan viajan
incansablemente en la parte de confianza
generar mayor confianza en mí con mayor
determinación enfocándome en cada uno de
los objetivos y en la parte de
exploración te quiero compartir algo
maravilloso que encontré no solamente es
la parte de explorar una cueva de estar
en un sendero me refiero a esa
exploración de abrir la mente a esa
exploración de la mente
es por ello que el día de hoy quiero
recordarte que los límites solo los
pones tú
si álex ando él fue un humble me hubiese
tomado la decisión de entregar su vida a
lo que más amaba quizás no habríamos
interpretado la naturaleza como lo
hacemos hoy en día el tomo la decisión
de vivir
tomo esa decisión
y una de las mejores y de las mayores
lecciones que le ha dejado la naturaleza
justamente fue el de libertad
el día de hoy te quiero preguntar que
debe pasar en tu vida para que decidas
comenzar a vivirla recuerda que la
montaña eres tú mismo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]